et il ya la boîte à puch avait on a
demandé aux équipes de production au nom
à notre équipe de production de bukavu à
percer et je peux vous dire que j'ai lu
de trois petits trucs
alors ça va être chaud je vais vous lire
d'autres petits trucs et j'aurai du très
très lourd à vous annoncer par exemple
alors julien premier truc tiens
christine kelly n'est pas la dernière à
aguicher les chroniqueurs en loge aller
parce qu'elle est gentille et christine
donneront une chaude c'est mathieu qui
le dit ça va je suis tranquille
exactement ce qu elle aime bassir il
sait qui c'est beaucoup ça fait deux ans
que je lui dis je la guiche pas en loge
non alors ne boudons maggie c'est
magnifique on peut cependant pas du tout
mais jamais je suis très respectueux de
cystine et sympathique donc et avenante
idées parfois pris voilà voilà pour de
la guiche qu'elle était amoureuse de
vous plaît phoniquement merci alémanique
mon papa platoniquement samaoui mairie
amoureux sur ça veut dire on nique sur
un plateau
[Applaudissements]
quelqu'un vous suivre assez alors
mathieu ne connais aucun nom du stage 2
au fait le test demandez lui le nom de
cinq personnes de l'équipe en dehors des
chroniques allez-y alors alexandre
guerrier ouais un assistant de prod
amauri à mourir de sa fille julie
raynaud la productrice
ouais aina plein alors du coup cinq on
aimerait nourdine ça ça qu'on pût
c'était avant nom de tpm pea si marine
qu'envoient les textos ouais avec ap
je vois des visages au rugby club
accueille ce n'est pas au maire d' une
bonne bah voilà anne on attend
maintenant il avait raison mais c'est
bon allez merci
alors qu'ils avaient raison les chéris
isabelle appelle tous les jours la prod
pour de monter une moto-taxi nom ou la
cessoie pas vous attendre les années
lire pour être à l'heure je suis obligée
après le soir je vais un danube prendre
mon taxi à la station de taxis notion
vous coûter cher
gilles fait sa diva au stylisme il faut
lui enfiler son pantalon et boutonnet sa
chemise c'est vraiment à la chemise
c'est vrai pantalon je fais tout seul et
qui fait dire à monsieur très bien de
moi jean-michel demande à la prod
d'arrêter de lui faire des fiches en
faisant croire que c'est pour préserver
l'environnement
c'est vrai comme à la banque payet
partout on n'arrête pas de faire des
papiers je trouve ça ça gâche
moi je suis senti à la cause
environnementale et chérie et là j'ai un
gros dos il va arriver sur quelqu'un oh
là là je peux vous dire non non non un
gros dossier un homme une femme
je vous le dis j'ai un gros dossier
savadogo gynéco way est beaucoup mieux
un butin enfin questionné 90 et vous
voilà donc matthieu delormeau on a vu
que vous ne connaissiez pas du tout le
staff mais c'est important aussi d'être
là on n'avait que kelly aguicher que
certaines personnes et valérie benaïm
oui paraît que vous évoquez
systématiquement des problèmes de dos
quand on vous propose un tournage ou à
un happening et ce bien avant qu'elle
ait des problèmes de dos masmoudi la
production je suis assez d'accord avec
eux
doc ne sait pas se servir d'un déodorant
on lui a déjà expliqué plusieurs fois et
pourtant il fait toujours la même chose
il le col sur son torse et appuie 10
secondes à a hâte de voir comment faites
vous en avez un vrai palais nous dont on
sait comme pour le parfum en fait cela
et vêtements mais l'ouest le col tout
près de ma peau a besoin d'avoir moi
j'ai toujours du déodorant zaba journée
ici chat à savoir comment tu fais
comment tu te mettes vidéo est vraiment
mauvais
c'est d'ailleurs là n'en sais rien pas
de plaisir comme ça et c'est pas
l'annoncer le faire mais ici on
travaille juste à quoi juste en
médaillon en médaillon
m
[Musique]
c'est bizarre c'est pas mal du déo
ensuite à la cela je ne dis pas ça alors
eh les mecs regarder lors de la galette
des rois de l'entreprise je suis
absolument francs
cyril a annoncé qu'il offrait des ps4 à
ce que obtenait la fève il y a eu 20 fev
de trouver mais personne n'a rien reçu
les ai commandé alors et jouer la
galette des rois c'est janvier que je le
dis aujourd'hui je le dis il ya le net
stan en régie le directeur généralde h2o
vouliez c'est lui qui tient les comptes
malheureusement ce n'est pas moi et je
lui dis aujourd'hui on veut les vins ps4
pour les personnes qu'ils ont gagné dès
demain on me dit que sur les 20 fev
trouvé il n'y a plus que deux personnes
qui sont encore dans la société qu on
trouvera se retrouvera les 18 autres
personnes
les eaux ont leur ps4 voyez en va bien
l'expérience a acquéri fumant l'âge
alors combien dit plusieurs fois que
c'était interdit je n'aime pas ces
soucis c'est sûr il y arrêter kim est
arrêté à ces arrêtés délit vous avez
serge et je vous avais fait déjà assez
de mal
v de v dit c'est bon vous mentez un
briquet quand vous respirez il a toi
vous êtes devenu menteuse mais c'est le
portugal qui vous a rendu montre
non mais elle y donnait un peu voilà
c'est ça voilà l'annoncé ça vous allez
voir là je vais vous dire le sait ça
allait très bien c'est ça je les aime
énormément mais je peux vous dire le
csii préfère la franchise bah voila
c'est à vous voilà à enfin alors voilà
c'est comme si voilà alors vous n'allez
pas me dire
benjamin pètre tout le temps sans
s'excuser pas dire que vous prêtez pas
même pendant les tournages et il est
mort de rire en plus voilà le début de
l'émission vous remercie non cb
démission n'ont demandé vous êtes un
petit peu enrhumé avant la projo
attention que les deux éléments sont pas
concomitance et sip est pour le premier
le fume ça par un coup de grisou
c'est donc c'est drôle mais je peux pas
rire à ses blagues
n'empêche que danser un peu qu'on prend
comme moi que vous faites beaucoup aidé
ans était très drôle franchement c'est
vrai il était drôle valoir m mathieu ne
rend jamais les vêtements qu'on lui
prête c'est vrai la regarder cette
baisse qui l'avait quand il est à
l'université il a jamais rendu
concernant le chocolat avec les
chroniqueurs font des grands sourires à
siri n'est ensuite ils se défoulent sur
les techniciens là c'est vrai vrai ou
pas vrai aussi voilà j'aimerais donc
hashtag tarbes à votre avis pourquoi pas
pourquoi parce que vous approuvez
ah bah alors je vous dire non mais oui
pas de parler mal aux techniciens c'est
pire oui à giuly au nom personne
n'arrive à le parler oui oui c'est vrai
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
enfin je terminerai par cru que j'ai
trouvée lors du repas mois serge epa qui
a mis sa merci en tout cas aux gens de
la production au nord arrête ça m à
cyril offre ses lunettes de soleil et
tout ce qu'il a sur lui à chaque fois à
ceux qui lui font des compliments sur
ses lunettes ou sur ses habits en même
temps il peut les offrir puisqu'elle lui
sont offertes
[Rires]
merci merci à eux en tout cas
franchement oui
qu'est ce que vous voulez dire ce qui
est on barbier et par elle et en espagne
c'est vrai oui au 7 mars et vous alors
je vous lirai barbier de séville en fait
un jour j'étais même avec des gt avec
des copains d'enfance kim et moi l'école
je suis bien mais qui c'est on part mais
je suis ici c'est le barbier de séville
est haut comme ça mekouar l'état jusqu'à
s'est vite tu vas